know those mornings in the 80s won't be
long they'll be back
and they'll be here for a long time yes
and those uh those day clubs will
sound real good at you know seven
o'clock in the morning i feel like i'm
ready for the pool
it's a little crisp out there this
morning for sure look at those beautiful
blue skies now we started our day like
this
yesterday and then the clouds started
coming in we had the gusty winds and
wow i had a little opportunity for rain
but of course
it missed us it moved so fast had a few
sprinkles around
maybe you got some light showers in the
north valley but this thing was gone
we've got temperatures in the 40s right
in the middle of town 45 north las vegas
sitting at 40 degrees
henderson here at 40 and nellis at 43
not much in the way of wind
we had some 25 30 mile an hour winds
yesterday wind comes back on saturday
for the weekend
and then again breezy days next week
we'll warm to the 70s though friday into
the weekend beautiful weekend
except for that wind on saturday and
then again next week we've got several
breezy days and even another chance of
some showers
the middle of next week and cooler 60s
returning as well so
make the use make use of these nice
warmer days as we head into the weekend
that system is gone
still spinning snow showers up into utah
we'll head over into colorado the next
big system
already knocking on the door of the
pacific northwest that's the one that's
going to scoot by us
on saturday to the north and pick up
some gusty winds for us down here in
southern nevada
68 today that's not bad we were in the
upper 60s yesterday
but today it will feel better with the
warm sunshine look at those mid 70s that
show up friday saturday sunday
and again some gusty winds on saturday
cooler next week and a slight chance of
showers on wednesday will be down
to the low 60's